- [Presenter] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website, or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
We are the paradoxical ape: bipedal,
naked, large-brained. Long the master of
fire, tools and language, but still trying
to understand ourselves. Aware that death
is inevitable, yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly. We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive. We shape the
future from our shared understanding of
the past. CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines to exchange
insights on who we are and how we got
here, an exploration made possible by the
generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Jean-Jacques] Today I'd like to present
you with some thoughts about Neanderthal
evolution and to what extent climate might
have influenced their evolution. But
before I start with the climate and
Neanderthals, I wanted to show you this
slide presenting, on the left side, a
Neanderthal, and a modern human about the
same age. And in front, you have two
skulls of extant apes, a bonobo and a
common chimpanzee. And this is just to
show you how Neanderthals are different
from us in terms of anatomy, in terms
phenotype in general. Modern humans and
Neanderthal's ancestors diverged probably
about half a billion years ago, whereas
bonobos and chimpanzees diverge much
earlier, probably somewhere between two
and one million years ago. And one of the
mysteries regarding Neanderthals is, what
kind of evolutionary process was driving
this very rapid divergence? The way we
like to think of the Neanderthals- the way
they are presented in the literature- is
this way: humans adapted to a glacial
environment, a peri-artic environment. As
a matter of fact, if we have a look on
this very jerky climactic curve, you're
going to see quite a few times today I
imagine, you can see that for the last
half million years, 95% of the time the
climate was colder than it is today in the
area where Neanderthals live, mainly
western Eurasia.
This being said, the climate was not
always glacial, the glacial episodes were
rather brief, actually, the most extreme
parts of these glacial episodes. And if
you look on this map, this is a map
showing the distribution of places where
Neanderthals have been found, you see that
actually they are not documented very
highly in latitude. The northernmost
Neanderthal ever found was found 52
degrees of northern latitude, which is not
so high. Neanderthals lived also in places
like Spain, and southern Italy, or the
Levant, that never really witnessed really
glacial episodes. So the question is what
in their environment, first of all, drove
their distribution, and also drove their
evolution?
The distribution that you see now is, I
would say, misleading somehow because it
is a palimpsest of the distribution of
Neanderthals through a very long period of
time. In other words, at a given point in
the past, they never had this extension,
so it's a sort of addition of many years
of distribution. It is very likely they
reach their easternmost extension in
southern Siberia and southwest Asia only
at some point in their late evolution. So
speaking about climate and the influence
of climate on evolution, we have quite a
number of studies showing how climate can
influence the biology and morphology of
modern humans.
One of the most spectacular features that
relate to climate in extant humans is the
body shape, in general. There are a number
of studies showing that the proportions of
the limbs, the shape of the trunk, varies
with climate. Basically, people exposed to
very hot climates need to cool their
bodies, so they tend to be slimmer, have
narrow trunks, and longer limbs. People
exposed to very cold environments tend to
be huskier, to have shorter limbs, wider
trunks. This kind of study is a
multi-variant study taking into account
many populations. It shows how you can
basically rank populations from the
tropics- on the right side you have people
from East and West Africa- up to the high
altitudes, so in green you have
European populations.
So if you take measurements of the body
shape of a Neanderthal and you plot it in
this kind of chart-- this is the case for
one Neanderthal very known called
[inaudible 00:07:34]. It falls beyond any
modern European and even beyond modern
Inuits, so it is said to have a
hyper-arctic body proportion.
Interestingly, if you plot on the same
chart early modern humans who came into
Europe about 50,000 years ago to replace
Neanderthals, they plot very close to
populations from modern Sudan- which, by
the way, it's certainly one of the best
arguments to make that come out of Africa,
besides genetical arguments. However, we
should be very cautious with these
features, because climactic adaptation is
not just a biological adaptation in
humans, it is also a cultural adaptation,
a technical adaptation. In other words, we
suspect that even if Neanderthals were not
exposed always to very cold climates,
because of the limitations of their
technology, the biological response might
have been higher than what we have in
extant humans. And as a matter of fact, if
we look at the archeological record, we
find very few archeological sites left by
Neanderthals in truly very arctic
environments. It looks like during the
coldest phases of the glacial episodes,
large portions of Europe had been
abandoned by the Neanderthals. There are
other features that have been said to be
related to climate in Neanderthals,
especially their very peculiar facial
morphology. They have a very strong nasal
facial prominence, this very big nose
projecting, and on the side of the nasal
aperture, inside the face, you have these
volumes which are sinuses, which.are said
to be very developed in Neanderthals in
general. In a sort of naive way, people
have thought for a long time that the
development of sinuses in Neanderthals
were a kind of insulation against cold.
This idea has been very criticized.
Actually, it's completely abandoned today
because we see more these sinuses as
filling an empty space between other
structures that are adapting to different
functions. It is more interesting to look
at another aspect of the face, which is
the nose. Actually, if you look at extant
humans, you will see that one of the most
varying parts of the face is the nose and
the shape of the nasal aperture. One of
these skulls comes from Germany, and the
other one from Zaire in Africa. And
immediately you can see that the shape of
the nasal aperture is very different in
these two individuals. There is quite a
number of studies showing that actually in
humans, the nose, and especially the inner
nose, is adapted to the climate conditions
in different regions. Primarily what we
have is a problem with cold and dry air.
Individual populations that are exposed to
cold and dry environments tend to have
nasal cavities that are higher and
narrower, in order to increase the
turbulence of the air that is inspired,
and to increase the contacts between the
mucus tissues and this air to warm it and
to moisten it.
The nasal pharynx seems to be more
depending on moisture, the nasal cavity
itself with cold. So what about
Neanderthals? Well, at first look, the
Neanderthal seems to match very much this
prediction, because they have this huge
nasal aperture that is somehow unexpected
if it was exposed to cold environments.
Actually this nasal aperture is especially
broad in its upper part, which is not what
we find in modern tropical populations.
But if we look inside the nasal aperture,
we see that there are a number of
structures that inflate the walls of the
nasal aperture in order to narrow this
nasal aperture. Although the nasal
aperture is very broad outside, the cavity
inside is much narrower and much more the
prediction we would make about a
cold-adapted population. Last but not
least we have now, a number of information
coming from paleogenetical studies, and
I'm sure there are a much more to come in
the future. But we know already that there
are a couple of features of Neanderthals
that we can relate to: the climate, the
environment. And I would like at least to
mention this gene called MC1R which is a
receptor involved in the red hair and fair
complexions. And very likely, at least on
the Neanderthals on which this gene has
been detected, we deal with populations
that have light skin color and red hair.
So we share some adaptations to the cold
environment in Neanderthals, but the
question is are there other effects of the
climate on their evolution? I would like
now to deal with something else, that I
found probably more important than
adaptation itself. One of the questions
about Neanderthal evolution is, why do we
have this divergence between an African
lineage leading to us and this Eurasian
line about half a million years ago? What
happened at this moment? Why then, why not
before? It raised the question of when
exactly we have the first Neanderthals.
And the first Neanderthals we have in the
fossil recall are about 400,000 years old.
They are found in England, they are found
in the UK-- in Spain. And this age, a
little bit above 400,000, has been for
some time in conflict with dates that were
provided by geneticists. Geneticists,
using a molecular clock based on
computations using the assumed time of
divergence of fossil groups, came to much
earlier younger ages for the divergence of
Neanderthals and modern humans, something
around 300,000. That was a bit problematic
for paleontologists.
But recently, because it's now easy to
sequence the complete genomes of parents
and children, we can compare this genome.
It has been possible to find that the rate
of mutation assumed by this molecular
clock was not quite right.
And new estimates came with a rate of
mutation much more reduced, [inaudible
00:15:34] was initially thought. And this
new rate of mutation is confirmed by the
study of some fossil material- this is a
femur of an early modern human found in
western Siberia, for which we have the
complete genome. We have the dating, it's
45,000 years old. So it's easy to compare
the genome of this early modern human with
extant Europeans and to have a notion of
the rate of mutation along this lineage.
It confirms this reduced rate of mutation
that has been recently proposed. So it
means that the time coalescence time
required for Neanderthals and modern
humans fits rather well this emergence in
the phenotype, in the morphology, around
400 or 450,000. What has been going on in
this time period? We have a list of
features proper to Neanderthals that we
see emerging through time by a process of
accretion, and it's basically a shift in
frequency of these features that we see
more and more along time. About 200,000
years ago, in the isotopic stage seven, we
have basically reached the Neanderthal
morphology completely. So the story
unfolds between, say, 450-- I'm talking
about morphology here, and a little bit
less than 200,000. And it goes at
different speed, depending on the
different anatomical areas, and we suspect
that one of the mechanisms driving this
evolution is not adaptation, it is not
selection, it is something that
geneticists call drift. And this drift is
mostly depending on demography. So what is
it about?
It's simple. You have variability of a
population in terms of genes and in terms
of morphological features, and if you
reduce the size of this population-- if
you reduce it dramatically, and then
re-expand this population, you are going
to have, again, a large population, but
with reduced variability just by chance.
Just because only some of these features
went through this bottleneck. And we have
something like that with Neanderthals
along the Neanderthal lineage- I could go
through several features, cranial
features, facial features. I'll just pick
one example which what we call
non-metrical dental features. And these
non-metrical dental features have a
frequency that increases along the
Neanderthal lineage. We know they were
part of the variability of Neanderthals of
the middle Pleistocine hominids before the
Neanderthal emerges, and they seem to be
fixed a little bit by chance in
Neanderthals and reach a very high
frequency in later forms. So what could
drive this evolution? We think this jerky
curve that you saw several times already,
in this period of time, say around 800 to
400,000, becomes even more jerky. And we
have 600,000 years ago for the first time,
first major glacial episode in western
Eurasia. We think that this first major
glacial episode resulted in, for the first
time, an isolation of western Eurasia, and
a dramatic reduction of the population
living there.
This is confirmed also, now, by
paleogenetics using the high-resolution
sequencing of Neanderthal genomes. It is
possible to make assumptions on the
evolution of the population size through
time, and we see that contrary to what we
have in the ancestry of modern humans, we
have around five to 600,000-- dramatic
reduction of the population size of this
group. So the story unfolds this way: we
have in the early Pleistocene western
Eurasian hominids, we still see a lot of
changes between southwest Asia, Africa,
central Asia, western Eurasia. And with
the isotopic stage 16, about 600,000
years, we have probably for the first
time, this separation that matched the
genetic data. We have another major
bottleneck with isotopic stage 12, and
soon after, this is when we have for the
first time, Neanderthal features emerging
in the phenotype of European hominids. And
let's say 200,000 years later, after a
number of bottlenecks, we have basically
fixed this Neanderthal morphology. So to
finish I would just like to say one word
about Neanderthal extinction, and I think
I-- I hope I convinced you that climate
played a major role in the rise of the
Neanderthals. The question is, did the
climate play a role in the fall of the
Neanderthals? There's a number of theories
about that, that Neanderthals got extinct
naturally before modern humans moved into
Europe.
What we think about the emergence of
modern humans into Europe is a scenario
that is a bit more complicated today than
it was a few years ago. We think we have
two major episodes of colonization of
western Eurasia, one corresponding to what
we call initial [inaudible 00:21:42]
sometime around 48,000. And a later one
for western Eurasia around 42 to 43,000.
It has been argued that in this time
period, the climactic curve is especially
jerky, and that that would have driven the
Neanderthal to extinction before-- or
facilitate the replacement by modern
humans. Well, I think when you look at
this curve it is very difficult to see
more jerkiness in this period than before.
I think Neanderthals survived all sort of
climactic changes before modern humans
arrived in western Eurasia, and I think
the main disaster Neanderthals had to face
was not a climatic disaster: it was us.
Thank you.
♪ [music] ♪